[Music]
were we blades in that one for the love
of snipes how many times do i have to
say it keep it singular there's only one
blade also show never gives us the
context for any of this if it does it in
another episode fine i'll give back like
30 sins but for now i'm all horned up
for the alternate gem dimension and the
show keeps rolling over insisting it has
a headache
hello morty gets cell phone reception in
space meanwhile i lose connection any
time a nearby squirrel farts don't ask
me how i know i just know okay painting
your toenails on your bed with no towel
or any kind of protection underneath
yeah that's a great point the 3d
holographic warning system however is
operating at full capacity i'd
appreciate the detail in this call
screen except that your screen darkens
when you have it next to your face so
there's really no reason for it to be
showing anyway look at all that work you
did for nothing rick and morty do you
feel ashamed come on come on
this works oh you touched the ocean
technically the ship is touching the
ocean rick and morty are still in said
ships so i don't see how the treaty
we're about to find out about with mr
nimitz has been broken kaboom you've
been lawyered now face the wrath of your
once and eternal foe mr nimbus sorry who
is that my
nemesis nimbus nemesis never named noted
nor noticed until now noteworthy nemesis
named nonstop normally this nimbus
nimrod not nearly known enough for
nemesis nomination i am mr nimbus he's
gonna say that a lot i mean i would too
if that was my name it's mr
nimbus it's a lot better than namor uses
magic ray to double the length of the
table but has to use a cloth to clean up
the wine spill sure why not said his
nemesis rick has a nemesis rick and
morty is clearly poking fun at shows
that introduce some random pivotal
character in a later season such as
cousin oliver and the brady bunch or eli
scruggs on desperate housewives but rick
and morty is only so good at poking fun
at these tropes because they're too
guilty of using these tropes it's the
classic comedy trope-a-dope and we ain't
falling for it rick and morty summer is
gonna dive into the marianas trench to
recover the forbidden shell that gives
him his power allowing your
granddaughter to dive into the marianas
trench to recover the forbidden shell
that gives mr nemesis power without her
parents explicit consent so time moves
faster in there
it's like a narnia thing i'm not a
beaver who believes in jesus christ
morty i think they call them bell
beavers they're a distant cousin to the
beliebers it's a long story also he
didn't ask if you were a narnian just if
it was like narnia in there i don't know
man all that defensiveness probably
means you want to believe in jesus or be
a beaver it's probably the beaver thing
mr nimbus is an ice-cold killer morty
pretty sure morty already experienced
the ice-cold killer sensation a few
minutes ago when jerry and beth declared
their love of porn to him
police a strange horny ocean man is on
my lawn horny cause he wears a speedo
likes to moisturize moves sensually just
cause he's sexy doesn't make him horny
jerry project much
fight
flee jeez nimmus sums up the entirety of
the human relationship cycle in five
seconds i don't know whether to take a
sin off for the intense but hilarious
depth or sobbing the corner
contemplating the mundanity of my
existence in other words yeah it's a
rick and morty episode leaving the
recliner chair reclined patricide fine
whatever terms term number one how does
nimbus not hear this he's right across
the table i accidentally had a video
playing with similar noises across the
table one time and now i'm disinvited
from family thanksgiving also where is
this camera exactly and did rick plant
it and if rick did plant it why didn't
he just grab the forbidden shell while
he was down there i thought you already
went i did i just just got a little busy
why would you make up a lie that makes
you look bad when the truth would make
more sense and take the blame off of you
yeah i got it but the adults wanted all
of it bing bang boom time to suck face
where is your wine boy richard i thirst
he's getting it i'm not sure why rick
thinks this because he didn't ask morty
to get more wine what if it gets weird
even just contemplating having sex with
a fish guy already puts this in the
weird category so you might as well just
go all in at this point jerry
the wine survives this centuries of this
isn't every end a beginning stay back i
don't want your stripped-down sundance
sci-fi
oh rick and morty how i have missed you
take your sin back for just being you
old friend can you believe he bought
that retrieval easier than i can believe
they've been running the simulation
non-stop all these years just waiting on
morty to return but sure yeah go for it
make us slightly more wet title of my
sex tape i just took some wine i said i
was sorry what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you people but it was morty's wine to
take so why does he think that that's
the issue here he realizes he's killed a
lot of their people right uh it is morty
though so i guess maybe he doesn't
realize this frozen in time forever
asleep in exactly how long has forever
been again morty leaves one time and
comes back a decade later but another
time it seems millennia have passed if
you think i'm not gonna send your
inconsistent portal time passage rules
just because you didn't officially
establish any you have severely
underestimated my willingness to stretch
for a sin why did i clone myself
genitals weird hoovy clone guy would be
excellent at tv sins let me deus ex
machina this let's go home i believe you
mean deus ex ricona you're gonna try to
be all excellent at tv sins and such at
least throw a portmanteau in there to
pretend to keep it fresh
oh well that's cool why because it has a
setting that disintegrates all clothing
except the parts covering the genitals
i'd go with convenient or prudish
bruvenian did you think i would let you
die alone richard
ah pelvis x junk in a see that's how
it's done
yes
time
i had nothing but time but
while rick wins is in pain at this nut
shot i feel the need to point out that
he's been standing here nonchalantly
ignoring chunks of flesh out of his body
either you feel pain or you don't rick
you can't have it both ways
you two are hungry yep good thing you
made a fresh plate of i'm gonna say
strained orange pulp mashed potatoes
with amber food coloring a pile of sunny
d slushy i'm not sure what it is but
don't you try to pull off that vomitus
mass's eggs you know better can i kill
god
summer took out an onslaught of
underwater foes in the previous episode
how would she not be useful when going
to battle anyone ensure she's a clone so
maybe that wasn't this summer but it's
too early in this episode to know that
sweetie don't get all worked up before
your job interview job interview show
doesn't resolve this i mean i know
that's the point but you can almost hear
the audible glee in the writers room
when they're like let's introduce b-plot
hanging threads so we can troll the
audience with this ultimately
meaningless episode and you know how
much i hate threads and things that are
hanging so jerry morty are shot side by
side but in the overhead view they're
now separated by a table and hey where
did that juicy plate of not eggs go oh
no they died this show has killed its
main character so much that caring about
them is like eating your eighth piece of
pizza i mean you still like pizza and
all but at that point you've eaten too
much but also once you get to eight is
nine really gonna make that much of a
difference so you stuff it down like the
meaningless hunk of matter it is and
wonder if anything even means anything
anymore hunt me hunt me somebody hug me
if sweaty death wish here truly wanted
to be hunted he'd be hiding in a bit
more stealth what he should be saying is
chase me chase me or kill me kill me
i'm mr always wants to be hunted yes and
how interesting did you think that would
stay joe then proceeds to hunt itself
for the next 20 some minutes making
another self-referential dig which in
turn makes my job even harder so ding it
i shall
golf well i don't see any stakes in them
summary of the biggest issue with rick
and morty at this point somehow makes it
into the episode and by somehow i mean
the writers intentionally put it there
as a meta wink to self-defuse any
criticism because they probably think
it's not a bug it's a feature but in
either case it is a sin so the new
family we think is our family suddenly
dies and i guess this is the part where
i remember that it isn't a new season of
rick and morty until we have a good old
game of forsmith monty the only
explanation is to how this green car
missed the arrival of a spacecraft and
the obliteration of the adjacent vehicle
is distracted driving put your phones
away people holy crap is morty call me
by your naming at the age of 14 when the
outside grows on the inside and then
reaches back outside your plant
addiction has gone too far how many
lavender shirts does one person who only
wears coral shirts need this armor
somehow flattens the basketball hoop on
the garage without a moving folding or
pieces of it flying off and also leaves
large sections of the roof and walls
unprotected rick would suck at purge
survival is all i'm saying decided it
was maybe better as a kind of kinetic
mislead for another special episode geez
ricky moore you sew up its own ass with
his fourth wall destruction then i swear
an episode in season six will just be a
static camera filming the actual actor's
table read it will be so clever
but then eat people yeah during this
scene i thought oh interesting i'm
eating popcorn too and then as each
murder devolves into organs and viscous
explosions my level of popcorn enjoyment
began to wane this is a sin for me
forgetting to never eat while watching
this show i'm not looking at your ass
public beaches summer you [ __ ] idiot
calling your granddaughter an idiot
while concurrently exposing your in her
direction jerry come on family emergency
a bigger emergency than my lemon
square's not setting you mean those
lemon squares that appear to be stacked
nicely on top of each other indicating
that they have indeed set pretty well
all right we've seen enough of these
decoy houses to ask the question are we
really suggesting that all these decoys
have been set up with not only identical
houses but in identical neighborhoods
and most importantly why do they all
have the driveway crack from when the
house was removed and replaced in season
one
i think you got the wrong house bro
analysis mode password eight zero zero
eight five
kind of expected a funnier password i
kind of expected a rick would have shot
another rick in the head already in the
time it took him to make that password
boobs joke are the golden circles the
decoys or the concentric circles and why
is there no text on the map so we can
point out inconsistencies this map is
confusing and is hindering my ability to
do my intended job of actually pointing
out real sins instead of just making
jokes or hindering my ability to make
jokes instead of just pointing out real
sins depending on who you listen to
analysis mode eight zero zero eight five
huh no but if these aren't this rick's
decoys then why were they on this rick's
terrible map analysis mode password
eight equals sign equal sign capital d
honestly the vertical bar number three
works better in most fonts go ahead and
throw in a few more equal signs while
you're at it am i right fellas before
you say anything they were already
killing each other and you saw that
through two walls also three spaceships
a lava gun a house engulfed in flames
and exactly zero nosy neighbors show
doesn't know how to suburb correctly
connery plays the spaniard but does
nothing about his accent presume decoy
rick would be excellent at cinemasins on
tv sins i say we split up some of us
take down squids while they're rescued
agent b story is off the track
simultaneously no thank you
d d conversations why are we wearing
these better question
where did you get these they have an
assortment of fabrics and foam to
construct these costumes did they make a
stop at the fabric store there's one
conveniently why is jerry even holding
an active bomb after the crash is it in
any way in jerry's character to be aware
of how to do something like this or even
want to do it in the first place it's
either accidentally convenient or out of
character and cindy is hungry today so
feast cine feast how exactly are these
restraints containing the smiths they
have room to breathe they have room to
wriggle out the top of these things
can't kill you yet the skin needs to be
fresh so why peel the skin off at all if
the skin is removed from its blood
supply it'd likely start to die pretty
quickly the peeled skin is already
unfresh is what i'm saying also you
can't simply banana someone and still
leave the victim alive
at least that's what jeremy told me come
on there's a place we can go and despite
knowing that all the clones sorry decoys
would also be somewhat programmed to
want to kill each other they do in fact
go is this decoy missing his pickle rick
doesn't appear that mr skin cut it off
and you can't spell decoy without the d
what about the squids the summers are
going to explain that the squids were
decoys who realized they were decoys and
wanted to kill the other decoys and sure
sure fine whatever but in a world of
apparently countless decoys have none of
them died before now to start this
asimov cascade have you met jerry like
12 percent of jerry's die within the
first year of existence
i mean is that something anyone wants
now the only way to prove i'm real and
not him is to isis expository
self-referential exposition the shield
lowers and somehow this version of the
family is battle charred and bruised
which seems unlikely because their
shield has been protecting them up until
now and also in the previous shot they
were completely normal i'll just point
out once again that no one outside of
the smith family seems to be interested
in this insane activity happening all
around them not one civilian passing
cars straight animals police officer or
really anyone is alarmed by what is
happening in these streets you want to
get in one more i told you so about
synthetic life or whatever this week's
theme is how are these mouths moving big
bird's mouth moved because one of the
puppeteer's arms was actually moving his
head instead of big bird's other arm but
clearly both arms are functioning here
as rick gestures around so what moves
the mouth i want to say technology i
want to believe technology and i think
it's just convenient animation because
those heads are as hollow as a
presidential promise
rick survives this
i think or decoy rick maybe survives
whatever this is someone survives
something that much i'm sure ha both
jerry stop fighting to hug
hunty mcpherson here one shot fatalities
the entire smith family but only wounds
rick for reasons and did you just
believe me oh yeah i hear it now you
should have hunted me what
since the show apparently wants to sin
itself i'll let rick handle it from here
were you significant like like did we
tee you up you want to be hunted god i
have so many questions
decoy decoys decoys decoy decoy decoys
decoy decoy decoy decoy decoys decoys
decoys decoys decoys
[Music]
decoys decoys the decoys he coil decoys
decoys decoys
decoys decoys decoy decoys decoy decoy
decoy
decoy decoys decoys decoys decoy decoy
decoy say decoy again [ __ ] you
this might be bold but i'm gonna have to
remove a sin before we even start this
dog here fishing for a t-shirt that says
compliments only is a great visual gag
look man game respects game however as
the sin lords death giveth they equally
doth taketh away there's absolutely no
need to censor the word patty here hells
yeah i [ __ ] love merch okay show when
you say you love merch and you flaunt a
shirt you sell it we have a new
prometheus shirt we showed off in a
video recently it's also available in
our store whereas i scrolled through
five pages of shirts to only discover
that this shirt isn't even available you
know though now that i really think
about it they really did spare me a lot
of horrible looks at the sunday buffet
rush my acid rain will destroy all
things green and natural but not the
very natural skin of the diesel weasel
or its very natural body parts in
general those are immune for reasons
there's only one solution for earth's
pollution
planet tina looks straight to camera as
if she has a polar icecap's chance in
hell of changing the lifestyle habits of
an audience which is currently juggling
their freehand from a reddit scroll an
energy drink in their own personal
yosemite shirt
what the [ __ ] was that
kidnapping also that was an obvious
ripoff of captain planet and by your
powers combined i will not have our
childhood hero mocked go planeteers
mother nature has enlisted the help of
four young adults from each major
ethnicity that's actually not racist but
the way the show pokes fun of it might
be great taylor murphy dumps me the day
before his hella big pool party and my
little brother's dating a phase four
superhero um actually summer i think
you'll find that planetary can't even be
in phase four because she isn't even in
the mcu cannon i mean she doesn't even
appear
just shoot me in the [ __ ] head until
i die a comment that is very triggering
while simultaneously meaningless after
that [ __ ] decoy episode what in the
name of sweet baby measures is going on
with jerry's breakfast how does he
expect to eat this soft-boiled egg if
his toast isn't pre-cut into strips
ready for dipping he can't afford to cut
the toast now every second he wastes the
gooey egg interior is slowly solidifying
also the egg wasn't even cooked and why
didn't he rescue the toast why is
breakfast three planets are all ending
in a delayed succession surely there
must be a multitude of cataclysmic
events be following a plethora of
planets across the universe if rick
really wanted to go on a doomed planet
bar crawl isn't his ship fast enough to
prevent their proximity to each other
from being the limiting factor or
failing this couldn't he use his oh i
don't know
portal gun if you don't want to help me
i'll find my own goddamn way to the
wildfire
kids tina girl have you gained weight
well i had a plant-based donut yesterday
just a half sugar is worst thing for
figure darling i don't know what's worse
about this exchange the fact that tina's
being fat shamed for eating a donut or
that said donut was plant-based i'm
going to send both just to be safe this
is freaking you out huh no what's
freaking me out is this phone fitting
into that pocket so are you two dating
asking this question to a kid
with your grandparent over and i can't
believe i'm going to say this
don't look now but someone's giving you
the big eye what in a sea of aliens with
big eyes all staring at them on the
party float you don't say
ready right meet me at the car calling a
ship a car one of these has to be hers
where'd she go where'd the purses come
from they left away seconds ago and
returned with 50 bags were they having
sex next to the lost and found room also
why would a race of aliens bring their
purses to an end of the world orgy and
then abandon them at the bar money would
be meaningless identification pointless
and whatever other products you keep in
your bag you kind of want to have them
on your person right also also many of
these purses are shoulder length and i'd
think their sensitive elbow orifices
would rub up on the bag and either
overstimulate or chafe or both
me why does this show make me think of
these things how do you let someone
permanently tattoo the wrong arrow
directions on your body i mean you're
literally wearing the reference on your
chest so you know better idiots that
pearl went away
isn't it interesting how they can summon
planet tina and whatever she is holding
but can also force her to be dismissed
without the item she holds this spell
was obviously crafted by the dark lord
that rules plots in the world of
convenience this really must be the
greatest party in the universe this
guy's loving it so much he duplicated
himself so he can enjoy it from 12
different perspectives neat he's a lost
honey calling a woman honey i'm actually
calling anyone honey you don't even know
me kristen from denny's oh
that's how you smoke marijuana i mean i
of course knew that because i smoked the
reefer all the time wow how about this
weather sure is unseasonably warm
tonight what is this mop made of that
would allow it to break a storage shelf
and obliterate a container
what are morty's teeth made of that
would allow him to instantly bite off a
finger what are his lips made of that he
could blast a firebolt out of his mouth
without any singeing
we've seen enough of these now that i
really shouldn't be surprised by how
quickly and remorselessly morty turns to
murder and yet his phone keeps going to
voicemail his phone has been ringing for
a minute and 43 seconds before going to
voicemail what sort of hell hole are
they living in they should be relieved
by their impending deaths also voicemail
which one of you ordered a pizza no one
ordered pizza what is this not ordering
pizza is always a sin morty shows up in
a murder pie hat and my question is did
he swipe a hat from a local pizzeria
with that name or did he stop at a hat
embroidery store and have this whipped
up for just such an occasion
imagine either being so dumb or having
so little regard for human life that you
repeatedly machine gun your boss just
because your intended target ran behind
her
i've never had a magical ring streaming
air forced into my mouth before but
let's say i had i truly believe my
instinct would be to keep my mouth open
rather than create an unimaginably tight
seal around said ring
i'm not a fan of gratuitous murder but
this right here gets my seal of approval
sorry i've been harboring that one for a
while okay i'll stop now
small consolation but this soon to be
dead slart of arson would be great at tv
sins not keeping your eyes on the road
while driving through what appears to be
an asteroid field that's right
girlfriend this is what you're up
against elbow hemorrhoids olecranon
set up prolapsed titties on more gluts
okay hitting your funny bone under any
circumstances is agony but i can't begin
to imagine how painful it would be to
accidentally catch these l boobies on
say the corner of a table you know what
i have someone i could check with aidan
a yes how much would that hurt it would
suck yeah that sounds right thanks
you're welcome
weirdos then i put my sunglasses on and
walked out like nothing happened what a
romantic story about our son killing a
room full of people i don't care if they
were technically in self-defense morty
just admitted to multiple murders while
casually playing whatever the fork this
board game is and no one cares and no
jerry and beth that quip in those mildly
withering stairs do not count as
disapproval i only want to spend as much
time as possible with your son my son is
14 miss i'm really glad that someone is
finally addressing the underage elephant
in the room but why is beth a the only
person to realize that this is sick and
wrong and b more outraged by this than
all of the recently described
boner-induced bloodlust there's only one
solution
whatever that solution is i'm fairly
certain it lays somewhere on the
spectrum after rhyming couplets but way
before multiple homicides
morty is crushed and runs away because
planeteena's current body count is 25
higher than his competitive
relationships like this are so toxic
this gay sex with my dad is terrific
paternal sodomy patotomy so der you know
what there's just some places i will not
dip my portmanteaus in
now you're grossed out summer this is
what's pushed you over the line not the
incest not the l boobs not whatever the
[ __ ] this was swimming through these
bodies and kicking this gropy tentacle
is what really took the biscuit for you
this works so why the [ __ ] wasn't it
plan a is genocide really a palatable
price to pay for the sake of rick's
party boner
well let me just grab my phone here
although both can be cloaca bearing this
crew drawing is clearly a frog which is
an amphibian not a reptile
cap should have antenna caps no cap so
beth is standing at the washing station
washing this bloody body part which she
then throws away she turns back to the
water to wash the blood off her gloves
but why wash your gloves at all when one
you're just gonna throw them away and
two you should be washing your hands
okay but we've been here for hours i
don't want to hang out at the stupid
horse hospital kids what's this thing
that's a breeding mount how are you
communicating so clearly with someone
who has departed the room entirely and
if the walls are so thin how does beth
not hear morty flip on the bang bang
ba-doop-bop machine i can't believe i'm
gonna ask this question but since we
find out soon morty is going to [ __ ] the
bojacker how exactly does he get his
morty junior into it he's practically at
eye level with the entry point drinking
directly from the carton while on a lawn
chair sitting on a slanted roof
come on yeah because rolling a barrel a
horse even from the street is much
easier than backing up the station wagon
to the garage reading from a great
distance away you know that race of
underground dwelling cannibal horse
people that were always fighting yeah
the chuds
what about them you can't just take an
acronym that has already situated itself
in previous pop culture and make it your
own and how would the acronym even work
in this form cannibalistic horse
underground dwellers it doesn't roll off
the tongue in a meaningful or fun way
kahud might be a terrible movie but it
got here first oh so what the [ __ ] is up
with the security at this horse hospital
no one here finds out a kid is mounting
the horse juicer why don't you trust
labels all right fine i won't test it
wait what since when does rick given to
morty's hysterics or even trust labels
goddamn your generation really picks
random hills to die on zoomers can you
give me a minute i'm trying to steer
around the bodies of our neighbors that
felt like gene knowing your neighbors by
the sound their body makes when you run
over them space sperm sperm from space
is anything a stretch for the smith
family they've seen countless
unexplainable things up to this point so
this new shenanigan should end in a
casual shrug this is the greatest
country on earth it is not don't blame
me i'm just quoting jeff daniels hello
hello sorry i'm late oh look a fumbling
disheveled an awkward scientist cliche
neat how do we deal with these or gaza
goblins who's gonna tell the writers
that sperm and orgasms are not
synonymous just because he oomphs
doesn't mean she zooms it's a fine
suggestion but i doubt their leader will
be a sexy queen that needs to be
kickboxed sexy sperm queen foreshadowing
says queen shadowing scream zigzag rick
and morty survive this no you're getting
dumber because that's a trebuchet i
guess the show has time to discuss the
difference between a trebuchet and a
catapult but not concern itself about
the giant hole in the aircraft right to
the top just the way you like it except
the water isn't to the top
get this guy a nobel prize
you became a woman today
yeah that checks
oh i'm so wrong about this guy he didn't
even buy us any time well maybe run away
instead of watching someone attempt to
be both the six and the nine the
stalling is really on you rick silence
in the presence of me i am the sperm
queen i don't even need to question this
one title of my sex tape in fact a lot
of dialogue could fall under many of my
titles space sperm sperm from space damn
they must be huge why would the sperm go
to the grand canyon we'll use it as a
placeholder and beat it later right to
the top just the way you like it i know
how to myself you need more than that
dummy you need a horse hand job solo how
did dan harmon get a hold of my stash i
don't know whether to be ashamed or
overjoyed why do you have the horse jerk
off machine from my daughter's hospital
it's kind of weird that rick knows for
certain this breeding machine is the one
in beth's workplace no oh but our
stallion is already here i get that
morty created all of them in the first
place but do they really need morty to
continue their race every spermable
person could be eligible for this very
disgusting highly sticky
nightmare-inducing situation that i'm
totally not signing up for a chance to
experience myself what was it like
fantastic
asking your grandson how his sexual
experience went sorry i just thought
maybe i could have repeated sex with the
horse machine without it becoming
armageddon you and me both morty you and
me both oh sh did i say that out loud
what did you do i got out of your eye
line
the show man you can't beat me you
didn't bring a woman that could kick box
totally fair but also kickboxist my
hands are tied form a perimeter protect
that egg at all costs or and this might
be crazy shoot the egg and destroy it
you slept with my daughter i did oh [ __ ]
i did tradestiality have you come to the
kingdom of chuds for forgiveness um
technically rick and morty were
kidnapped to the kingdom of kahuds so
they didn't come here willingly to do
anything chads don't forgive humans
chuds eat humans this is out there even
for us it is not right i i love you too
princess ponieta lying
and why aren't they spraying it on the
egg take three steps back amazing
jonathan show proposes the idea that the
president of the united states would
know who the amazing jonathan is that's
nancy reagan this [ __ ] i would say that
none of this hopping from sperm to sperm
should work but really we could just say
that about the entirety of this show mom
i promise to use condoms even when it's
butt stuff okay we have a lot to talk
about tonight waiting this long to talk
to your kid about butt stuff always be
honest sometimes it will hurt people
sometimes it will help
but always be honest sports illustrated
kathy ireland is making a lot of sense i
don't think we appreciated sports
illustrated cathy island enough in her
heyday and that's a hundred percent of
sin a giant incest baby in space still
makes more sense than 2001 i guess
jerry can you watch the kids tonight oh
uh no we can't watch the kids it's guys
night not telling anyone else how to
parent but why is beth even asking jerry
to watch the kids summer's old enough to
watch morty and they've left the home
alone before in prior episodes i'm just
saying this feels like a purely
arbitrary way to get beth involved in
some hell-raising activities later on in
the show also this dartboard location
are you sure that's where the grapes go
morty because i feel like they'd feel
more at home beside that [ __ ] fruit
bowl that we've seen before for being in
a ridiculous place in the living room
and we will keep sinning until they
[ __ ] remove it and they're all
crowning i have to go show leaves the
achieving the rare triple crown joke in
the stable yeah most people would call
that family
you're so good you have to like it or
you're sexist that's flatulist i'm not
sure if this creature has a tongue peen
or a mouth china but either way this
penigina dentata is getting us in hey
we're in luck gang they've got the
entire smash mouth catalog smash mouth
shaming what they had that song you know
the one there was haying now and they
couldn't get enough of their baby and
and yeah they were
putting your feet on your eating surface
with shoes on is that classic snake boy
that guy just keeps getting bigger
commenting on bruce jetback snake
dude this [ __ ] plays it close to the
vest thinking running tap water will
drown out the sound of you talking about
someone in the next room
[Music]
also i just watched jurassic park on
cable explaining your references you
could be brilliant rick and morty but
you're a coward
black swan seriously though
i'll freeze your amber so how exactly
would that threat stop summer from
touching which means rick is going to
die because of you unless you you go
offline this computes this computes
oh yeah
as much as this bueller's on for some
time i'm surprised the title of this
episode wasn't rickus mortler's rick day
off morty why would a mailbox society
live in buildings shaped like mailboxes
if it were a letter or package society
sure but do humans design houses that
look like giant humans dogs maybe but
not humans
going postal summer morty and shut back
survive this why is it that whenever the
smiths bring some rando on one of these
adventures said rando is never freaking
the [ __ ] out shut back should be shut
backing his pants right now or at the
very least asking how the [ __ ] they're
flying in space except i don't get
pleasure from mocking others because i'm
not lame
uh no sin here just really great show
being really great
i mean i have to add a sin or cindy
won't move on but we're totally not lame
next
what is that essence of hell how did
they get this drink or these cups they
didn't have any of this on them when
they entered through the hell gate i'm
not sure what's going on here but i am
sure that morty needs more water intake
looks like he's peeing orange juice i
hope it's at least pulp free what the
hell bruh thing i say every time there's
more than three clasps to undo somehow
makes it into the episode why would i
like a change i'm the most powerful car
in the universe what that means you
don't have feelings actually yes it does
it's a car i am a car not a robot wrong
you're both a robot's simply a computer
that can transport itself and do tasks
which you can you could have said you
aren't an android since that has more of
a human connotation or you could have
said you aren't a change former since
that has more of a don't sue us i swear
they aren't transformers connotation
isn't a doorknob a virgin not mine
what do you expect i mean she's my why
i almost want to take a sin off for the
show pointing out that borat isn't all
that funny but then again this made me
think of how unfunny borat is and that
irritated me so jerry's the best talking
about someone in the bathroom not
realizing said someone is in the
stalling near everything being said
cliche also how did they not realize
jerry was in the bathroom these two were
outside when he said he had to go pee
after a week rife with a fetter of sin i
yearn for a taste of his cringe sitting
episodes of the office casually dining
while face peeled hell spawn are around
this is gonna lose this place at least
one of its michelin stars remember beth
is just a cartoon remember beth is just
a cartoon remember better also there's
not nearly explanation enough for how
rick has created these outfits is beth
really bleeding did they stop at a
costume store does rick really have a
hole in his midsection now is he wearing
a marlin a marlin there's no marlins in
baseball i mean hell oh it's painful so
i love it this pleasure equals pain
equals pleasure diatribe goes on for all
the some time i think the statute of
sanitations is about up on sending rick
and morty producing complex devices out
of thin air like this arm cannon so in
order not to let it slip by i'll just
point out that something can't come from
nothing something has to come from
something and you can yell nano
technology all you want and it still
doesn't make it any less of a cheat
zippers near genitals and yes i'm aware
most pants already have this it was
always a bad idea see cringe cannot
exist in a vacuum it needs to be
observed the tv sins motto somehow makes
its way into this episode like what i
did with the chip in her head is she
gonna be okay summer is concerned about
not allison hannigan but not the cindy
and alien mailboxes she obliterated
earlier could this be the end of mouse
trapping me opposed i mean one can help
but because of wiki fan pages and fan
fiction i'm guessing not
sorry i farted the rare fart joke
bookends look when you bookend with back
end i got to get some respect and by
respect i mean sins the lasers seem
awfully close to the large american flag
what if there's a draft sure leave these
cameras operational but shoot the others
with utter snot makes total sense
morty's laser cannon is aimed upward but
by the time the beam takes out a bell
and liberty it has managed to shift
trajectory enough to cause me to send
every possible person place or thing
that was in the line of this plot shot
also with weapons like that it almost
makes you wonder why taking out any of
the other decoy families or sperm
monsters in previous episodes was a big
deal at all it was a trojan horse morty
never trust the french that's where i
ceased once again all kinds of going
down at smith's house and there are no
nosy neighbors to be seen as anyone that
works on this show lived in the suburbs
there'd be like a watch party barbecue
going on next door with at least 20 to
30 people in attendance there'd probably
even be a bounce house rented to keep
the kids occupied well happy
thanksgiving to me celebrating yourself
can't wait to see what a shimmer does to
my prostate shimmering your prostate i
don't even know what that means but
certainly it's sinful synchronize
digital exposition sync digital position
coop not on thanksgiving how would she
know who was calling coop does he have a
specific vibration pattern for turkey
time that little race car driver you got
bacon in your belly what world you want
him rearing up in parental
predestination
what happened to the clothes they were
wearing did they meld into the skin of
the turkey because when they get turned
back into humans later they're no longer
wearing the clothes yeah yeah it's
cartoon blah blah blah but have you
watched this channel before all due
respect sir i know flesh when i see it
those flesh covered robots should buy us
some time but where did rick get the
flesh you know what some things are okay
to be left unsaid i'll still send it for
lack of explanation but i'll be okay not
knowing about rick's leatherface
practices ship go stealth but only after
flying directly overhead so we can
clearly see where you are in relation to
your mission and forget about asking how
the ship escaped the bubble back home
unnoticed we don't ask those kinds of
obvious plot hole questions anymore huh
turkey marines the president came to
play but you knew this already right i
mean you did the entire expositional
plan thing and even showed fully armed
marines who won't recognize me so why a
shock let it be known that it cannot be
an official episode of rick and morty
until a questionable egg dish has been
placed on their dining room table
that's weird id chips for fincher and
rodriguez are glitching yeah super weird
that you've not been monitoring them the
entire time you've turned men into
turkeys people watch their
vitals wearing heels on a lawn also
wearing socks with heels on the lawn
here comes dipsh right on schedule
nothing can go wrong now aside from
things immediately going wrong i'm
curious how the original plan would have
gone from here in order to be pardoned
rick would have to be the selected
turkey how does he plan to stand out how
would he have ensured that he was going
to be selected i know it's not sexual
favors turkeys are notoriously selfish
lovers hold your positions as a feeding
friend blueberries have been available
in this dish for any of the birds to eat
at any point so why would their sudden
presents on the ground initiate a food
frenzy i hate to be morbid but if you
use the angle of the gun barrels as a
guide every bird in this pit should be
dead now sir we are losing the mental
game down here the mental game i think
your bigger issue is that someone up the
chain forgot to mention there were
people inside turkeys in this chamber
and that all machine guns should be
turned off because bird stomachs are
just filled with air so when you punch
them whatever is inside just cannons
outward super scientific does anyone
find it suspicious that the laboratory
now only has six turkafire thingamajigs
they didn't know two of their own
wouldn't be returning did they but why
does this turkey look anything like the
president when it's transformed the pill
was simply a transmitter assigned to the
president there was no mention of it
being dna encoded and why would it be
look at this dumb piece of [ __ ] earlier
humans had no issue communicating with
the marines in turkey form but now they
can't understand the president sounds
like a load of turkey to me so to be
clear the president planned to straight
up murder rick and morty for charring a
little piece of the constitution and
activating a war machine that he doesn't
actually care about in the first place i
know i know questions like this matter
about as much as questioning fire under
the ocean in a spongebob episode but
still why is there fire under the ocean
i thought we already rehumanized all the
turkified marines forgetting fincher and
rodriguez i am selling new york to
france
and giving all of the money to congress
i want to sin the idea that these
tactics would prove to be this simple
but sadly i'm more inclined to believe
they really are this simple
that's right murmur and when you're done
get me some pants perhaps the most
confusing part of this episode is how
rick managed to turn the president back
into a human without a lab we skip over
any transformation explanation entirely
and you just know that wherever they
went had something that would have
worked for clothing but i guess if you
have a you really just want it to swing
around there is more bare ass in this
episode than both boss baby movies
combined also why does rick randomly
have suits to fit the president there
won't be a single bird left in dc
something birds aren't real has been
telling us the whole time i can't stop
looking at these two this man's torso is
longer than hers but her legs are longer
than his and the circular footrests are
down so low they both appear to either
be very short or the stools aren't made
correctly and wow his hair grew back
quickly sir we've got rick and morty
coming in what appears to be an
unlicensed star wars adat or as the
millennials say 1880. oh yes the is die
hard a christmas movie argument for star
wars fans except it's even more annoying
pilgrims of the corn i wish to explode
this works
oh they love each other perplexing sure
but even more confusing maybe the fact
that the far superior race of aliens
willingly returns to their secret
chamber to re-enter some sort of
cryogenic status so they can be called
upon again at some point in the future
by a civilization that they do not have
to support
kids
singing in the car also somerset person
that always holds their note after the
song is clearly over to show off we get
it cindy you know how notes work no way
it can't be this one's just for the
commenters that said that rick might
have missed jerry being in the back seat
in a previous video dude just spotted
the glint of a gotron ferret out of the
corner of his eye from a couple hundred
thousand miles away so i think he could
clock jerry sneaking into the trash
saucer after he unlocked it chew on that
commenters look no one said i wasn't
petty it's not a gotron ferret morty
it's the blue gotron ferret so a gotron
ferret then that's how it all began to
my sister it was just another game there
will be a lot of morty and summer
narration in this episode and yes in the
end they make fun of the fact that there
was so much narration in the episode so
one might think that we would let that
go but one is naive and will receive 20
dings is your sentence joe thinks it's
all cute including snippets of actual
episodes in the opening credits but now
that we're here this section is
redundant and therefore wasteful and
therefore sinned mine smells skeleton
smelling your boot not only is that way
too much spaghetti and meatballs but how
exactly did they serve themselves off
that plate and leave it so undisturbed
and if they got theirs from somewhere
else why did they even make a serving
plate at all the smith family doesn't
know how to food correctly told you
let's just get gene from next door and a
homeless guy considering this episode
decides to have some actual continuity
by bringing the incest baby in space
back i'd also like to note in that exact
same episode rick runs over gene and
therefore he would not be available for
gotron activities get your asses into
some anime spacesuits and despite not
having been told where they are given
any instructions they do rick's tube
sucks the spaghetti off but doesn't spit
any out yeah i heard it too
where are we zip-lining through
futuristic metallic tunnels to you're
going to the center of a volcano
incorrect the correct answer is you're
zip-lining to a transport ship that will
take you to the center of a volcano so
close rick so close did i just monorail
from my kitchen to hawaii just to
regroup in outer space above my kitchen
jerry and this show continue to be
excellent at tv sins i swear the show
tries to forgive its own sins so much it
might as well be well organized religion
guys we did our best they did not
i i can't believe this is working
neither can i summer and morty should
either be passed out or vomiting
profusely now after being swung around
like that not to mention they're upside
down when being fired wow it's so
ridiculous that this group could pull
all this off with no training that i'm
surprised the show hasn't sent itself
for it yet how do we just hit buttons
we're too big to fail there it is
holy sonny d look at that purple stuff
what kind of circulatory system would be
pushing that amount of fluid through it
at that pressure even with a clean kill
i'm simply not buying this amount of kai
juice rick showing affection will never
not be weird and will always be a sin i
swear the only alien animation rule for
this show is is there somewhere you can
put a nipple or a nut sack then do it at
nip sack animation all creatures large
and small deserve vaguely sexual
external appendages having spaghetti at
a cookout hot head rick he got that name
because he was prone to dramatic
outbursts explaining nicknames that need
zero explanation oh they got him not our
problem turning a blind eye to murder
gotron montage goat montage go trash the
last time we saw morty's gotron ferret
come out of the parking garage he didn't
need to reach for a ticket he just left
furthermore why does he even need a
ticket are you saying at the end of the
adventure he comes back to the parking
garage and gets a ticket that he now
needs to leave it and those go transform
the the go-go tron these transformations
make so little physical sense that it's
clear this episode attended the michael
bay school of transforming things let's
just say we're the rightful owners of
these ferrets then why were they
scattered and buried across the universe
yeah scattered and buried let's go with
that we mean in a more general cultural
sense
overly emotive anime shaming are those
boob bucks how do these three even know
he missed out on going to disneyland for
that matter how do they even know they
have the right morty morty was supposed
to be security i i stepped away all
right that's a strange way of saying you
were kidnapped dad you know that's not
what i do around here no i'm not your
dad i'm a version of him but how does he
know that's not his summer how does he
know that's the summer that is the
rick's second in command and why do all
the ricks dress differently and have
different personality traits but all the
jerry's beth mortys and summers are
virtually the same i'm not sure how this
show ever expects to be successful with
this kind of shoddy logic work i mean
look at me i'm easy to make happy which
is why nobody gives a [ __ ] i am this
statement is so depressingly true i'm
giving a sin for it which makes me happy
which means no one cares but as you guys
recall and as a lot of people keep
bringing up morty and i did accidentally
create a giant incest baby only rick and
morty could pull off a chekhov's giant
incest baby ex machina through a full
minute of exposition and still make me
consider removing sins for it instead of
adding them after further consideration
i'm adding the sins anyway because we
all have a part to play in this crazy
world and my fate was decided long ago
if this is a gotron from gotron's from
gotrons do you know how far a trip it
would be from these robotic appendages
to the head no me either but that's not
going to keep me from sitting how
conveniently fast they got here say
hello to my little me title of my sex
tape but how did you get here where did
you find him how do you still have your
suits how did you know where rick would
be who changes the america diaper if
incest baby has to launch a missile from
his rear port man when it's time to wrap
up an episode rick and morty skips all
the interesting stuff also this is an
incest baby right do incest babies have
better capabilities to float around in
space without a suit this baby isn't a
space vehicle or the last jedi's
princess leia so what the heck is going
on here ratatouille in your giant incest
space baby without explicit consent
episode does not contain a boob world
episode expects us to believe that rick
would help pack the car for a trip he's
not even going on are you sure rick i
know i know a cruise doesn't sound like
an adventure on paper what a cruise only
sounds like an adventure on paper all
you can eat food the ocean views random
encounters with mysterious strangers
it's only once you're on board you
realize you're trapped in a floating
bacteria prison with half-cooked salmon
the threat of death below in the rocking
waves and a dude named rusty who can't
quit telling you about how his 2001 ford
150 just crossed 300 000 miles morty i'm
trying to stay humble right now rick for
real ionic coaster deployed what does
rick need an ionic coaster for when he
has so much free space on that workbench
right next to him garage ai is just
showing off at this point approaching
pause pregnancy in p minus j
christ
it's worth mentioning every once in a
while that despite being here to sin it
the show continues to find new ways to
make me laugh so take your rick and
morty gets a sin off because it's
freaking hilarious cliche and let's move
on how can a mind be hidden by itself
inside itself the first question
christopher nolan asked before starting
every screenplay somehow makes its way
into this episode suggestion don't go in
right the ai is loose enough to offer
fellatio for its own survival but still
rigid about saying command words like
suggestion before every sentence pick a
lane shallow hal yeah yeah hop to a
different timeline grab a version of my
friend that suits me best that's not how
this works and why not exactly did rick
just place that iv in one movement with
no tie off and without looking like i
get that you can do something enough to
be good at it but even the best
phlebotomist wouldn't dane defend the
main vein oh excellent i get to keep my
clothes i thought for sure i'd have to
be naked to go through something this
artsy why does rick care about his
clothes when is rick ever given he's
naked or clothed if you looked up down
to free ball in the dictionary it'd just
be a picture of rick saying wubble up a
dub dub now i got yolk balls title of my
sex tape no wait that was now that's
what i call yokeballs23 my bad you see
an older version of him come through
here
talking out of just one side of your
bosom seriously you've got two jabber
jubblies use them both opening a porta
potty without knocking first why was my
ninth birthday party in a pine tree pine
tree pizza is still at least 19 better
than what they serve with chucky cheese
so what's my deal am i sentient do i
have free will who does
covering the same ground is free guy
i'm coming with now that i know my life
is a lie wow you really are 35.
30-something shaming random convenient
pants that fit perfectly are random and
convenient and fit perfectly also
chafing can we both die in here are we
damaging our friend's brain i i don't
know any of the rules welcome to the
club the trick is just to pretend that
none of it matters and that making meta
jokes about it makes it all okay but we
suck at that so here's five cents
situation not looking ideal rick and
bird person survive this also it's bad
enough when human characters talk to
themselves as a way to force some
exposition but an ai construct what kind
of a logic chip would have to be
installed for a computer to start
thinking out loud thinking to themselves
is their whole gig i am rick's garage oh
like a like a jarvis like like jarvis
and iron man well that's a strange way
to say what the [ __ ] this garage with a
dying man hooked up to some sort of
cyborg bird creature is talking to me
also mcu nerds this is where you being
this leads you're not my fault i'm yours
this is all fun self therapy and all but
rick isn't engaging with his younger
self he's engaging with how not michael
keaton's birdman remembers his younger
self so why is argument if you die in
your friend's brain you die in real life
citation needed your life isn't real and
i didn't save it take off all your
clothes but why all of his clothes real
rick already has pants on your values
are wrong facebook this battle of blood
ridge goes on for all the some time why
would you not revisit this oh i don't
know maybe uh the ending the dark knight
rises okay you matter to me oh look the
show that spent several seasons teaching
me that rick has exactly zero moral
compass and is a complete dick to almost
everyone he meets in the service of
humor is now asking me to have emotions
about this the answer is no why the [ __ ]
are you risking your life for that
[ __ ] taking the wrong message from
the lesson you don't get to tell anyone
what's sad man you're like a one-man
mount sadmore so i guess like a lincoln
said mario i mean the statue of liberty
was right there man everyone knows what
a cloaca is do they it's not like
there's ever been a company out there
that based an entire t-shirt around one
sorry but we do not get to choose the
ones we love but we can't choose our
friends and we can't choose our noses
but we should never choose our friend's
noses
wait rick sanchez you're under arrest
for making me spend two years in earth
high school i bet this show would be
really fun for people who could remember
all the details of all the other tammy
plots i've got the memory of a goldfish
so all those call backs mean nothing to
me actually goldfish have been proven to
have better memories than we thought so
maybe more like the memory of a dog or a
bee or a what was i talking about again
oh well make the noise thing change the
number thing oh my god i'm a memory we
just sat through all that stand up for
nothing but in a world where you're
aware of multiple universes and multiple
use why would your first instinct be
that you're a memory when you see
another rick come crashing in okay
listen everybody my name's rick and this
is my new friend bird man and his
friends we all just met at this festival
and we're so high we formed a band oddly
enough this is exactly how sugar ray was
formed i'd like to point out that this
clock still says 2 pm which it said when
all this started and don't be claiming
inception rules because discount ava had
plenty of time to offer b-plot bjs to
random passers-by while they were out
and yes it could just be a dead clock
battery but that's boring and also means
i couldn't give this in
pretending prisoners have servers they
go around and dish out food to the
prisoners does this look like a
white-collar crime prison to you goodbye
mr cookie president electing a cookie as
a president why would you like anyone or
anything that you know for a fact will
eventually crumble also that's not a
cookie that's a wafer and i will need
you to kindly get out of here with that
nonsense how does this universe work the
camera is candy the mic is candy the gun
silencer is candy and the lollipop
appears to be a candy weapon of some
sort so why would a gun or a sword be an
actual weapon and not some other form of
candy i'm not sure which is more
convenient the morty somehow had
thousands of gallons of water readily
available to dump on a lava monster that
he knew precisely where the lava monster
would be or the portal gun itself i'll
send all three son of a [ __ ] he marked
it how is morty just now seeing this i
assumed the portal gun had some sort of
scientific woo-woo that would zippity
zap a portal to life after activating
the portal juice but apparently just
falling onto skin activates a portal
just fine we find out in a moment that
the opposite side of morty's hand portal
is not connected to a garbage dump but
rather the leg of a stranger for this
amount of garbage to pour through nick's
thigh he must be buried in trash but he
isn't hey how do you think i feel i had
the ultimate stash hole and now i got a
kid in my thigh first world problems
good luck finding someone that can be
told 80 000 times how replaceable they
are anyone who has ever worked in a call
center oh look a failed attempt at the
humorous pull nondescript lever to do
something incredibly specific cliche
good thing it didn't land on gene
because we know he's dead from that
other episode this season and when we
pointed it out before everyone agreed
with us and no one called us out on it
so i'm sure that won't happen here
simultaneous crow snatching is severely
questionable commence bird on a wire
scene does not contain a goldie hawn or
mel gibson also when did rick even train
them for this he literally just caught
them outside and brought them in here to
begin pavloving them with the bird feed
damn just
i've always said my favorite jackie chan
move is the one where the broom comes
out of the portal in his hand classic
chan convenient escape route through the
only window on an otherwise windowless
building is convenient damn it he must
be showing the gun off to his stupid
crows it's not fair kids also i like
surprise gun hidey holes as much as the
next person but this secret cabinet
should have been easily spotted below
the table based on how high it lifts not
drinking enough water pee clear people
morty is that what i think it is the
perfectly convenient appearance of the
very item you were looking for what is
that nothing i find it odd that the
gamewheel is the first thing the crows
fixate on rather than the anti-crow
graffiti all over the walls not now
garbage goober get back in your hole
rick is a dick to garbage goober our
first adventure discounting the
psychiatric hospital as an adventure
that's not how extinguished and
discarded cigarettes work i know we're
not supposed to question how rick's
magical scientific things do their
bullsh but his arm goes a really long
way and i just don't understand where
the mechanical bits are stored when not
in use pressing something to your face
that is dirtier than a toilet seat
you don't get it do you how you were
able to secure a jet pack and how you've
already mastered it in this short amount
of time no no i do not i i thought we
were both victims of rick's abuse
thinking that mutual abuse means mutual
friendship also how did nick track morty
being portal buddies doesn't mean
they're automatically portal tracking
buddies does it how does any of this
episode work
morty survives this for getting to clasp
your safety harness and sure he's
missing a hand but he didn't even try to
secure it with the functional one he has
left lucky for me abandonment to my
bread and butter if rick had the
multi-gun attachment why didn't he lead
with that when he first got on the ship
you were supposed to die then maybe next
time kill rick when you have the drop on
him instead of tying him up so you can
bondly exposit your plan [ __ ]
humanoid crows i'll always be your
grandpa morty i'm just kind of obsessed
with crows now abandoning your grandson
due to a crow fetish this would mean a
lot more if i didn't already know there
were more seasons left and they're not
changing the theme of the show to simply
morty or rick and crow rick will be back
there will be a reset and none of this
means anything this is a rick and two
crows of lies i suppose one might think
i'm about to remove a sin for this
emotional scene of rick and morty
breaking up but instead i'm removing one
because i appreciate that this show has
taught me to not give a [ __ ] about
anything that happens in it shutting off
emotions is healthy thank you rick and
morty thank you watch sitcoms on your
sneakers can you imagine the amount of
neck problems that would exist if this
became a reality did the chiropractor
guild sponsor this segment
[Music]
show does not contain chapters 1 through
12.
this owl does not exclaim loudly and
angrily about dropping his cabbages oh
come on you know this flower wasn't here
a moment ago sure looks badass but we
want to see this owl man bloodied and
broken at the base of this pummel tunnel
he's anti-heroic
because he took out one of the hinch
owls is luke an anti-hero every time he
shoots a stormtrooper is bond an
anti-hero every time he defenistrates
some random blufeldian guard is uncle
joey an anti-hero every time he insists
someone cut something out also why is
blue goblin group even running he's
clearly on your side if you were gonna
get out of there i don't think you
needed to wait to suss out rick's
anti-hero quotient
good luck i've never had a thousand
crows fly down my throat before but if i
did i highly doubt i'd be able to say
anything audible afterwards also wasting
a thousand crows when a few grains of
rice would have done the trick what
that's an urban legend okay fine then
wasting a thousand crows when a single
alka seltzer would have done the trick
what that's an urban legend too well i
guess this is now a sin for any avian
hating society that needs two distinct
urban legends about how to make birds
explode psychos what's the point here's
two i count eight nine if you include
the sword sure you only use two of them
for your owl triss section but how is my
four-year-old nephew supposed to learn
to count correctly with this kind of
confusing phrasing guy who screamed to
run decided to stay and cheer hypocrite
oh uh two crows you remember morty crows
are not capable of hovering also these
morty cameos and rick and two crows are
forced and getting out of hand we get it
you used to have this thing with your
grandson on a different show but that's
not what this show is about so let's
focus okay episode does not contain a mr
mole map paki-chan or bubrina the
unrealistic body image witch okay maybe
these humanoids have soft round skulls
that squish like fruit when they roll on
a table but that is just dumb evolution
come on puss a fur was right there
you've had a thousand adventures with
these crows in 13 episodes this may be
the last time you ever lay eyes on me i
hope that's not true morty because you
look like
shh and this is not how i want to
remember you the reason i choose not to
attend high school reunion somehow makes
its way into this episode setting aside
that this isn't even how real crows
sleep does rick strike you as the kind
of person that would be down for this
kind of crow habitation agreement while
i appreciate the hilarious live laugh
love art and the attention to the triad
details my laughter is broken by the
much more important fact that crows
contain no teeth and have no need for
items specially designed to brush them
we immensely enjoy each other's bodies
what oh no king shaming wearing clothes
under clothes for that long wait that's
it the long way to chapter 13 of rick
and two crows ends after just five
minutes who will avenge pussifer will mr
mole map ever be saved from captain
eagle eye's lair will the silver scurfer
find a way to cure his dandruff in time
ah i guess i'll have to go back to
sitting rick and morty but that means a
whole new intro to wade through i guess
i could eat the yogurt in the fridge but
what if the
[Music]
show requires watching rick and two
crows chapter 13 to understand what
happened between the end of last episode
and now and why morty now appears as a
middle-aged schlub geez guys why all the
homework that seems like it's worth oh i
don't know 21 sins sure i should be
paying attention to the family's reunion
conversation but why is the wall of
watered down sherbert color who
purposely paints their walls like this
thank god this is the last episode of
the season maybe by season six i'll
forget this atrocious hue hi i'm
citadel's new mascot andy because this
place wouldn't be home without ricks and
demorties except rick and morty never
uses an ampersand it's always the full
word and so i believe this is actually
amper sandy who has somehow escaped the
magic kitadel home to various pins and
or tellers morty survives this working
i'm almost ready to sell out so 27 year
old morty gets close to fit but 40 year
old morty was given a shirt size too
small none of us wanted to see that
discolored and distended mid-section of
middle-aged morty but the second he
reveals he's evil we're gone show then
cuts to an overhead shot of the dinner
table that includes a jello mold dish
which is the first reveal that president
morty is evil and i have a hard time
believing either rick morty would miss
this obvious clue tell me how one might
bring down the central finite curve all
right time to go morty i want to know
what he's talking about me too i'm sure
it will be a completely coherent story
point that i won't need an advanced
degree in physics a few days to rewatch
old episodes and five hours of in-depth
mining of the rick and morty fan wiki
just to understand well that would never
happen can you give me 10 more seconds
literally ten because now it would be
six nice attempt at being excellent in
tv since rick but that took two seconds
so technically you still got eight oh
i'm fine with that make it two five like
i said would have been a big help for
you to tell me but i should have
everything i need from you now if you
were stalling to finish rick's brain
scan then why did you bring up anything
that would make him suspicious in the
first place evil geniuses should be
called evil morons check out season one
episode nine rickheads excel seer
ruining the hunt for the true rickheads
who wanted to figure this out for
themselves this is why we're with them
this is why we're alive what the [ __ ] no
idea man you're on your own with this i
mean dadoy i'm basically inspector
gadget i would have gone with inspector
convenience but fine sending it either
way who am i to judge how the writers
decide to develop this fight but also
why the [ __ ] isn't rick pulling out his
big go-go gadget guns right now does he
like it it's a metaphor for capitalism i
think i've seen this before you created
a being that gets off on you getting
hurt and then transfers that energy back
to you to use on others so basically
it's fifty shades of vibrate yum that
was close let me try that one again so
basically it's fifty shades of black
panther and white panther because
together they are gray panther damn i
should have quit when i was ahead
tonight i do that thing i want to do
with the curve thing title of my sex
tape hopefully we can snack some
untainted fluid at the source and get
the [ __ ] out of here title of my sex
tape this lazy [ __ ] the whole place is
gonna blow no i don't trust you morty
just watched a whole slew of rick and
morty be devoured by their portals and
he chooses not to trust rick right now
rick's only consistency is his desire to
survive but now morty decides to belabor
things this two full minutes of silent
backstory is pure cinematic awesomeness
it's moody propulsive and informative
without the usual clunkiness that comes
along with having to do this much heavy
expositional lifting take us on off for
being true artists r m i mean r and m
but also you knew when you did this that
i couldn't help but sin two full minutes
of confusing and pretentious exposition
summed up as oh
dead wife call me two-faced if you like
but i prefer the term multi-faceted what
is this tubey thing and is it always
here would you have to drive over it to
get to the garage will it pop a tire why
is hoes casual murder in front of the
neighbors is casual i feel a lot better
having seen all that yeah so much
sympathy and emotion now that i've seen
him brutally and callously murder
thousands of other ricks because how
could rick not his wife died i am so
moved they still got a way out they
never thought of operation phoenix and
me if i can't remember back two years
ago as to what that is huh i can barely
remember the plot lines of shows i
watched last week i throw that stuff in
my brain bin and destroy it with fire
now you want me to recall it by raising
it out of the ashes and bringing it back
to life like some sort of um
fire death reversi bird even if i did
remember that episode i'd probably also
remember that morty's were never part of
the deal but i don't so i'll just send
that this morty has no nipples i'm gonna
be honest i don't have the slightest
clue about what's going on here i think
evil morty's breaking the curvy thingy
that separates the genius rigs from the
dumb ricks by launching himself towards
a space anus fueled by the blood of rick
and morty's who tried to use the
operation phoenix call back while our
rick and morty are trying to escape the
resulting gravitational pull by using a
unity metaphor drive booster as the
citadel is flooded and poisoned by
portal juice and eye patch morty finds
himself in the quantum realm until he's
needed by vindicator's end game i guess
i'll just have to wait till the season
premiere next season which i'm
absolutely sure will clear everything up
yay
god why do you hate me when i love you
so much
i'm scared morty i can see the end
cold i'm cold i'm so cold
actually your father and i have been
very sex positive lately we've been
watching pornography hey man got a big
box of porn for you
is that mr nimmus nimbus i hear you can
talk to fish
right there sugarhoof i'm moving a
little slow tonight i had a hot pocket
for dinner you will be the one to end
our pain to the pain
decoy family you made more clones you're
clones you're copies of people out here
in the world what clones what copies
what are you talking about
my spinach pus saved them that's great
good job very good watch it they're
still hot
what the [ __ ] you think you're doing
down there you're making decoys you make
a copy of a copy it's not quite as sharp
as well the original we can work this
out just stop trying to kill each other
mistake you made was you killed my
friend
so
i'm gonna kill each and every one of you
and the only disappointment in it for me
is that i only get to do it once you
ever make a copy of a copy i like pizza
i like it
[Music]
nice bieber
wait who the [ __ ] is that i am the borg
they're heading for vegas vegas baby
vegas
where's your costume this is my costume
i'm a homicidal maniac we got a baby
a science baby
what the cute little pink bunny rabbit
the langoliers don't don't even exist
you just made them up storming your
castle on my steve milady
[Music]
stop talking like that
[Music]
[Applause]
this gay sex with my dad is terrific the
line must be drawn here
this far no further how are you doing
that with your mouth collect the whole
set last chance to pee on me if i had to
i'd pee on any one of you
i'd like to ask you a few questions
we're touching rick's stuff summer he
said no no uh-uh uh-uh please god damn
it i hate this hacking crap low-life
butt-based miss grant butt-face
miscreant what if sydney killed casey
and steve why would she do that maybe
she had the hots for steve would kill
them both of
you're just moody you got stuck with the
marlin
fish give me that fish
nerds
roger roger what's our vector victor
i'm here today at the uh
on
because the earth has been attacked my
military advisers at the pentagram have
managed to do the impossible
i need your clothes your boots and your
motorcycle wear three across the bed not
a stitch of clothes on
i made it to shell city and i beat the
cyclops and i rode the hassle off and i
brought that crown back
whoa
i think my life is like
flashing in front of my eyes
since when does this house care about
alien lives we don't even watch british
television
from london
you're going to the center of a volcano
i
immediately regret this decision
[Music]
sometimes enough is enough
enough is enough
we're offering to help each of your
families complete their full goat trunk
in exchange for some concession why do
you have to talk to me like that all the
time right i gotta know something meow
meow meow meow meow meow
meow in puerto rico when we picked up
those two uh
well i guess they were prostitutes but i
don't remember pans
oh [ __ ] you a wise man's life is based
around [ __ ] you the united states of
america is based on thank you
[Applause]
oh that's all at once
and not
instantly to be sure
are you sure you don't want to come with
us oh i wish i could but i don't want to
excuse me did i pick that name i have so
many names
i am indeed down to clown i can make
things out of clay and lay by the bay i
just made why was my ninth birthday
party in a pine tree what you were
looking at are memories
in this case pertaining to one
individual hello hi good afternoon
what i want you to think about what
you've done kent and from now on stop
playing with yourself
it is god i need your clothes your boots
and your motorcycle
we lost germany
we lost friends
if we lose today we won't get the fart
enough
i know the pressure on you is enormous
two minutes to drop
candy citizens we are going to war
i have crossed the horizon to find you
that that's how we lost our cable guy
well maybe i shouldn't have come at all
jerk off
stop those poor boys that's what they'll
call us
[Music]
wait
are you my father
no but i stole your egg and mutated your
brain wow somebody's been busy i did it
because you hurt my feelings i learned
it by watching you
what yes log all kids love log
starlight mission accepted what we can
do is break his age in two places remove
the middle and graft its ends back
together that sounds really violent
jerome never questioned my commitment
again
i took my mind off the pain by reminding
myself that when i eventually did stand
up i'd be exactly two inches closer to
the stars
hey you were supposed to be my left home
how will i get out of here
in certain times like these i think it's
important for me to say my tiny little
nipples went to france four stones four
crates zero stones
zero crates
it's just as well i lied that second
seat's a toilet and i'll see you in hell
my brains are going into my feet
and love
gone forever